[Music]
people really want to stop about talking
about brandon shop and then you never
the people that want to stop by talking
about brendan shaw are his fans and they
will look to me and they'll say
stop talking about brendan schaub
and i'll look at them and say
no
want to see
a younger brendan shop a little when he
was a little less stupid sure or a
little less punch drunk i guess i feel
like even if there's haters out there
whatever on twitter or wherever they're
at or they don't like me for me i just
feel like if i could literally just sit
down and have a conversation with them i
guarantee you they'd be a fan
childlike wonderment is i don't know how
to describe anything other than everyone
loves me when they meet me when they
meet me
and nice
and generous and generous i'll help
anybody and funny
he's funny
at least at least they would understand
where i'm coming from because it's just
it's just tough because all you do is
see me on tv i fight in the ufc and all
you do is see that you don't see the
aspect of my verse what was that thing
that [ __ ] dick said in the in the
mom's sketch i i think i think his mom
is watching saturday morning cartoons in
her head
she's swamped all the time i always
think of like when they do the homework
thing like
he's a little child his little boy
everyday life and just and i'm a good
guy you won't meet anyone who hangs
around me for a while who's not my
friend
everybody on trash tuesday bobby lee
every comic in new york has met you most
comics in l.a who met you but not in
your face every pudding you tried to sue
every content creator on the internet
yeah it's a lot of people dude feels
like it's more than just a couple i
don't consider a friend i'm a good guy
you won't meet anyone who hangs around
me for a while who's not my friend who i
don't consider a friend
and by the way i tell you what i'll
we'll stop making brandon shop stuff
when two buttons stop releasing just
fire ass clips that he's been finding
yeah two buttons is two buttons fault
yeah oh and
annie leaderman
was on some show i don't know what show
this is
apparently it's the sound paneling show
where the whole studio is just sound
paneling
well i mean
no i get it if you're like
you got to do what you got to do i'm not
i'm just just funny it's well plus it's
a really good analogy
for her to be literally right next to
the wall
know just right up against that wall
what
honestly if she leans back a little bit
she's gonna hit it she's gonna [ __ ]
crash through it like a [ __ ] cartoon
character and leave a cardboard cutout
in it she's gonna [ __ ] she's gonna go
through like the kool-aid man she's
gonna go go through it like [ __ ]
chevy chase at the end and nothing but
trouble you know what happens when she
hits the wall next time next time
brandon goes hey you want to blow me in
my truck she's gonna go oh yeah
and then she's gonna ask him why his
liquid is red
i felt like i went to my grandfather's
funeral and or my grandfather's uh
casket his grave
um when i was in connecticut my mom was
like oh your grandfather's and i haven't
seen him since i was like 15.
back up i dug him up i started [ __ ]
blowing him oh my god poppy
i don't know it's i don't know i thought
it was a little fun it's a little
raunchy but whatever got poppy how's he
look poppy
gringo poppy
you knew what you were doing of course
wouldn't you do the same thing
[Laughter]
is he mexican my welcome
and i'm sure somebody knows who these
people are and then the chat room
they're probably like that's that's
billy bob booboo and his
and his girlfriend flooply loop and they
do a show called the la lasers or so i
don't know these la comics so i know
that i seem stupid i don't know al
madrigal or whatever so yeah no you
you've never seen this podcast it's
called dope sesh
and they hang out and [ __ ] talk about
the scene man no cap they just talk
about the scene and the craft
ah
enough of you
what did you call it the set the sesh
dope
no they call it dope sash because they
smoke weed during the show man
oh god hold on i got something for you i
got something for you here i think you
could do this hold on
here it is where's the ethan klein now
no here you go
yo we'd be busting though oh straight
sesh though we buzzed i thought i
thought it was an ethan klein mask i
thought he was going to start twitching
a lot
and asking terrible pre-written
questions every la comic now is the
zoomer meme though am i wrong
they're all the zoomer so what's your
podcast about oh man dude it's called
dope sesh we just smoke weed man talk
about the comedy craft and like the la
scene
it's pretty cool it's an original show
somebody goes our problem is we don't
have the app that identifies la comics
in the wild i think it's called la
comics go where you scan them
who's this
sorry
she put the casket in the trunk i put it
in the middle
oh god i don't know if we're allowed to
talk about that oh no we're gonna get it
sued uh oh
no we're gonna get sued
i don't care
i'm on t-man i'm on team annie if
anybody cares nobody cares listen okay
nobody cares old lady
you look like a pasco county mugshot i'm
happy stopping at a freeze frame she
looks like a pasco county mugshot i'm
happy sandy kane is doing all right but
i mean what is this podcast she's on
yeah
yeah suck my [ __ ]
he looks like someone cultured a nancy
pelosi [ __ ] to like biopsy like so so
you know what it looks like remember in
preacher when they made the [ __ ]
clones of jesus yes the [ __ ] clones
of nancy pelosi nancy pelosi's humperdoo
[Music]
the first time yeah i
then
some more of his buds having a little
roast
like it's about to be a wwe promo right
he's ahead
loving it i wore my good shirt for you i
love it absolutely look at you straight
out of [ __ ] oh i saw it
i didn't see this clip but i i saw this
episode yeah i saw some i didn't see
this clip either so this is this is a
good one andrew schulze's closet rob it
is
i have autism yeah i said earlier i'm
like is brendan schaub having an estate
sale since he was
he was brutally murdered last week
[Music]
how about one more time for forge cortez
everybody there he is
[Applause]
a lot of energy you on [ __ ] hgh bro
what's going on here you got that
[ __ ] ufc fighter energy seemed
genuinely angry when you got paranoid
you seemed like a weird guy to smoke
weed with
i would be frightened
yeah you make bread and chub look pretty
damn good
[Laughter]
they don't respect him no he's now he's
this isn't like joking with your boy
this i hate him it's so much fun
to finally see yeah like everyone start
to come out and go like yeah [ __ ] this
guy like they used to never take shots
like this
now everyone does i have one this is a
throwback
but i i just sometimes you like doing
classics up there right oh no oh god i
can i already saw the title
and i i
i can't imagine how bad this is gonna be
how would you say that name
bear grylls that's his name bear grylls
okay the the survival guy bear grylls
the guy who stays at the four seasons
and then films like he's surviving that
guy
um
pretty good gimmick
i'm not
i don't [ __ ] on people for one night of
camping and then you just go back to the
hotel it's the same way i like the top
gear guys dude all they do is go around
the world get hammered and drive fun
cars like
[ __ ] yeah i want that job make fun of
each other and put dildos on their cars
and [ __ ] that sounds great oh it's a 20
250 000 supercar and we've put a dildo
on it like why
you should see the old ones would be
like oh we put [ __ ] on the back of
hammond's car well back then they didn't
care like what he did what dude my
favorite top gear gimmick of all time
and royce made me watch this one day
like years ago was
when uh
two of them took a plane somewhere
and uh and and uh jeremy what's his face
uh um uh
you know the domain guy um he [ __ ] he
he had clarkson jeremy clarkson had to
drive
and the two of them had to fly and he
had to beat them in a car so he was
trying to make their life a living hell
and he calls the airline and he's like
yes of course we've got the top tiers
that we uh purchased for top gear um the
the the two gentlemen sitting there they
are horrible alcoholics and you are not
to serve them any alcohol and the ladies
like okay we've added that to the list
airlines will absolutely like if you
bought the tickets they will honor that
request so he made the shirt the whole
flight they got no drinks either we
can't would you like it would you like a
juice or something that was [ __ ] that
was that one was one where i was like
you're a [ __ ] dick bro sorry so let's
see how you say the name
dude the royal air force or something i
think that's what they're called man
some of the baddest ass dudes i've ever
met bear grylls
beer growls
beer growls sounds like something like
when you've had too many beers and you
start doing those little weird mini
burps
beer growls sounds like something a guy
fieri would eat at a diner where it's
like crawlers but they're big so they're
called beer
bear growls
is he one yep he used to be you mean
bear grylls bro
theo vaughn's had never given a [ __ ]
he's always busted on brandon's job oh
bill griles beer growls is uh
is a early onset sign of diarrhea i
don't know what station you're
and if any any doubles the best part
about brenda that i love no it's beer
growls i'm pretty sure i'm pretty smart
and he's gonna tell you that's that's
that was from a a lifelong stuttering
thing not the fact that he can't read
also
wouldn't you trust theovan i've never
known theo vaughn
to be a guy who doesn't speak properly
no that's a very good point like as a
matter of fact i think
in my and i like theo von but i think
that sometimes he plays up the southern
thing a little bit like because he's
actually a smart guy and i think he kind
of plays up the joe dirk gimmick a
little bit because that's his thing yeah
because of course no i'm not blaming him
i'll make a couple tree bucks here but
larry the cable guy don't really talk
like that either i hate to break it to
you but yeah like other than his i mean
he definitely does have that accent
cause he's from louisiana but he
definitely plays it up but i've never
heard i've never heard theo sound really
dumb no you know like his whole gimmick
like you said is like the mullet man
it's like hey man i'm just happy to be
here dude man i'm here to [ __ ] drink
some beers and [ __ ] crush and puss at
this party dude like but he's not a
dummy yeah he's a dude that i've always
liked theo i'll never not like theo he's
like the only one from this little crew
whose dad wasn't like an hbo producer or
some [ __ ]
jewish power broker